Adjusting her disguise, Zhu Yingtai
prepared to bid her parents goodbye.
She had always been a dutiful daughter—
staying home
and creating works of embroidery
that brought her parents pride.
And yet, although only boys were allowed
at the Confucius Academy in Hangzhou,
what Yingtai truly wanted
was to go to school.
She begged her parents
to let her attend dressed as a boy
and, seeing her determination
and clever disguises, they finally agreed.
However, they only gave her permission
when she promised
to keep her true identity a secret
and eventually return to the traditional
path they’d set for her.
Elated, Yingtai began her journey
to Hangzhou.
On the way, she found herself
at a crossroads,
unsure which route to take
when a young man approached.
As their eyes met,
they shared an instant connection.
Yingtai learned that his name was
Liang Shanbo,
and that he’d be her classmate
at the academy,
so they walked the rest
of the way together, rapt in conversation.
Yingtai realized that,
despite her meticulous disguise,
she felt that she could
finally be herself.
The two decided to celebrate
what they thought would be
a long, close friendship,
and became sworn brothers.
At the academy,
Yingtai buried herself in books
and studied with Shanbo
late into the nights.
The two felt at home so long as they were
at each other’s sides.
They shared a room, but even though
Shanbo questioned her about it,
Yingtai always used the bathroom alone
and buttoned her thick robes
up to her chin— no matter the weather.
Now and again, Yingtai heard students
muttering about her secretive behavior.
As months slipped into years,
Yingtai continued to excel at her studies
and felt like her past—
and intended future—were lifetimes away.
Yet the whispers grew louder.
And after three years,
she had no choice but to leave.
Parting tearfully, Yingtai asked Shanbo
to visit her.
When Yingtai returned home,
her parents announced that the Ma family
from the neighboring village
had sent a matchmaker
to ask their permission
for Yingtai to marry their son.
They’d found it a fitting match
and accepted.
Trying to hide her disappointment,
Yingtai honored their agreement.
But as she prepared for another new life,
she thought of Shanbo.
Meanwhile, he too was distracted—
his studies dull without Yingtai near.
When Shanbo finally visited
Yingtai’s house,
he came upon a young woman.
He was about to ask for her brother,
but as their eyes met, he recognized
the young scholar he’d always loved.
Shanbo knew he couldn’t stand
being separated from Yingtai again
and asked her to marry him.
But, heartbroken, Yingtai told him
that she was already promised to another.
Shanbo was devastated, but he understood
that Yingtai had to abide
by her parents’ wishes,
and they parted again.
Shanbo fell ill and grew weaker
by the day.
Worried, his family sent a matchmaker
to the Zhu family.
But, because of Yingtai’s
current engagement,
her father refused the proposal.
Doing otherwise would bring their family
public shame.
Shanbo’s Illness took a turn for the worse
and, sensing he wouldn’t live
to see her married,
Shanbo wrote Yingtai a final letter.
If Yingtai loved him,
he asked that she burn incense
in front of his tomb
when she was on her way to the Ma family.
When Yingtai’s wedding day came,
it also felt like a funeral.
As the procession wound through town
under stormy skies,
Yingtai broke off and knelt
in front of Shanbo’s tomb,
lighting incense and offering sacrifices
through her tears.
Suddenly, a clap of thunder sounded above
and a lightning bolt shot
through the tomb,
fracturing the stone.
Without hesitation,
Yingtai threw herself in.
As her parents rushed
to rescue their daughter,
two butterflies fluttered
out of the crack.
This time, Yingtai had transformed
for good.
Finally free, she could float forever
with Shanbo at her side.